l'idée m'est venue un soir de concevoir
un produit technologique personnel qu'on
ne met pas son bureau ou dans sa poche
mais comporte à son poignet un matin il
ya un collègue qui arrivait avec le
monde samsung et la team il l'a vu la
diva penser pareil pas et qu elle fait
pareil apple watch connecter à votre
iphone vous permettra de gérer votre
quotidien d'une manière intuitive la
montre elle est reliée directement en
bluetooth ou en wifi à votre portable
du coup ça ça pompe et la batterie de
l'iphone n'est déjà que de base se tient
pas pour brancher votre apple watch
nous avons imaginé un moyen facile
rechargez votre montre c'est extrêmement
simple mais c'est surtout tous les jours
1 parce que la batterie la paloise se
tient pas la journée non et puis c'est
pas le même câble c'est celui-là
non c'est pas ça c'est l'ancien un peu
le watch mesure précisément vos
activités sportives
quand je fais du sport lamonde vam
indiquer le nom de calories que j'ai
brûlé le nom de kilomètres que j'ai
parcouru et même mon rythme cardiaque
si génial quoi par exemple vous à
découvrir combien de kilomètres
récemment mais moi je fais pas de sport
par contre j'aime me tue qui mendient
clore avec ses bras nous avons développé
un tout nouveau moyen pour vous
connecter intimement avec les autres
comme attiré l'attention d'un de vos
amis avec une simple pression qu'il
ressentira dans son poignet je l'utilisé
très régulièrement avec mes amis tu m'en
sers jamais je m'en sers jamais ça tient
ses limites chiant c'est limite
chandelle voilà c'est encore très bas
c'est encore tim wec ljubicic syrie est
ce que tu peux dire intime d'arrêt
pourquoi ça danse le calendrier attendez
je lui revient j'ai pu me battre
vous pouvez également envoyer un dessin
que vous faites directement avec votre
doigt ils ont laissé sa réplique j'avais
dit qu'on ne mettait pas ça mais on veut
on peut pas à dessiner sur 3 cm comme ça
à regarder à moi j'essaie de faire un
arbre pad par exemple c'est super dur
également les imprimés ça représente un
arbre une femme on va voir si ça les
amuse et un intime
c'est marrant ou pas les pulsations nous
avons créé trois collègues
nous avons créé trois trois collections
distinctes d'abord l'apple watch
disponible à partir de 649 euros
l'apple watch sport des 399 euros et
bien sûr nous avons pensé à toutes les
bourses
si vous êtes très très très très riche
nous avons l'apple watch édition allant
jusqu'à 18 mail aux 18 millions
c'est super cher t'es ouf alors
franchement 18 millions sachant que
l'année prochaine on sort la paix
l'ouest 2 en creux 18000 euros pour 18
euros en plus on peut sécher de trucs on
peut s'acheter une voiture une golf golf
5 portes familiale vous pouvez également
personnaliser votre mot en armes petits
fonds de commerce en campagne pour 18000
euros
envoyez des émoticônes animé places de
parking à bagnolet pour vous dix huit
grâce à un bouton
retrouvez vos contacts presse 25 iphone
6 16 giga
j'ai calculé vous pouvez aussi échanger
votre pulsations cardiaques avec vos
amis tiens je viens de recevoir le coup
de mon ami johnny il est plutôt élevée
commence à licenciement commence à
laisser ainsi ben vous êtes trompés
c'est pas possible c'est peut être
maintenant mais ça fait trop longtemps
que dans la boîte des danois nous sommes
arrivés un produit d'une rare intensité
technologique mais ceux qui en parlent
le mieux ce sont les utilisateurs ou
même quand apple a annoncé la police
moi j'étais l'un des premiers à
précommander voilà et vous pensez quoi
des gens qui disent que les fans d'apple
sont prêtes à tout acheter même un
débouché at apple adrien des bouches et
apple qui est sorti on va prévenu à moi
j'ai touché ça une tablette j'ai tout
c'est quoi ta tu là c'est quoi cette 500
euros s'ils sont attendus au matelas
plus tard elles ont battu
nous sommes vraiment fiers de ce produit
car chez apple ce que nous voulons faire
c'est rapprocher les individus qui ont
pu être séparés par la distance où les
événements se sentir proche ensemble
avec un produit simple et personnels et
relier toutes ces personnalités pour
créer un futur meilleur
l'émotion
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo merci
aux chinois d'avoir conçu cette fausse
montre apple watch à 40 dollars sur ebay
au bouton sur le côté ne tourne même pas
je sais même pas ce qui est écrit dessus
ainsi quelqu'un ligne chinois je
remercie également julien jocelyn natu
et que marc pour leur participation à la
vidéo et je vous remercie d'être 7
millions d'abonnés ça un truc de ouf si
on fait ça très bientôt dans une
nouvelle vidéo thion
[Musique]